pero caramba
nadie más de corazón que cara más
cuerpos
no recuerdo al mes pero corría el año
1999 me convocaron para hacer un casting
de los miles que hacía en esa época de
modelo mientras terminaba la carrera de
ciencias de la comunicación en la
universidad de buenos aires para mi
sorpresa era para ser azafata de una
aerolínea que ya no recuerdo
él no o el sí o el no sabemos nos
llegaría la semana que viene o nunca
como solía ocurrir
la respuesta fue inmediata el puesto es
suyo bienvenida este es el salario la
llamamos la próxima semana para
coordinar detalles
un frío hilado recorrió mi cuerpo
bajamos el ascensor en silencio con mi
hermano lucas que me había acompañado en
esa oportunidad caminamos unos diez
pasos por avenida córdoba para esperar
el 140 el bondi que nos llevaría de
regreso a nuestra casa en unos aires
cuando de repente una claridad
una intuición que brota de mis entrañas
y va a cambiar mi vida para siempre lo
miro mi hermano y le digo no esto no es
para mí subamos y digo que no
cuando llego a casa
contenta con esa paz con esa sensación
de libertad que da cuando hacemos lo
correcto llamo a mi madre mi madre
responde y me dice pero maría candela te
pierdes de una gran oportunidad era un
gran trabajo un buen salario yo siempre
quise ser azafata
pero yo no yo nunca quise ser azafata
nunca imaginé en mi vida arriba de un
avión siendo azafata
argentina vivía una de las tantas crisis
económicas pero una crisis institucional
sin precedentes
cambiábamos de presidente como quien
cambia de lápiz labial
mi oportunidad quedaría muy lejos de
argentina
a seis mil 483 kilómetros para ser
específicos de mi reconquista del alba
una de las cadenas de medios más
importantes del mundo me contrataba en
miami
como escritora y productora de línea
para luego
convertirme en la conductora de ocurrió
así
y yo que llevaba ocho años al aire con
altos niveles de audiencia y que con mi
ingreso elevaría aún más no fue fácil el
camino tuve que adaptarme a hablar
español neutro tenía un profesor al que
nunca poseen pero florecía en colores y
sabores arme tribu arme equipo tuve que
integrarme a esta comunidad
hispana/latina que crece todos los días
y yo era parte de ellos yo entraba a los
hogares hispanos todos los días a las 5
de la tarde
tenía 27 años y el mundo a mis pies
cuando creí que este va a ser mi vida
presentando noticias un llamado
cambiaría mi vida otra vez mi manager me
confirmaba que ocurrió así se iba del
aire sin muchas explicaciones con
niveles altos de audiencia live snl
gustavo me mira y me dice ahora nos
vamos a divertir camelinas
tú qué quieres hacer
yo no sé si a ustedes les han hecho
alguna vez esta pregunta pero es muy
difícil de responder una adrenalina que
corre por el cuerpo
generalmente no tenemos tan clara la
respuesta
mucha gente prefiere no hacérsela nunca
yo en ese momento de caos responder
rápidamente presentar noticias así como
estoy y morirme en un set de televisión
gustavo volvió a reírse
me dio una vasija y me dijo pone aquí tu
sueño y sueña en grande cadena eres
multifacética tú no sabes el futuro que
te espera en la televisión de eeuu
unos días después en las oficinas de
william morris en ese tiempo tenía
agente manager y publicista dijimos que
no al noticiero nacional de la cadena
tenía miel
no sabía qué iba a pasar con el futuro
sin embargo la cadena abrazó la decisión
me convirtió en imagen y bandera y aquí
por todas las estaciones del canal en
eeuu
me transformé en la conductora de
ripley's aunque usted no lo crea siendo
la única mujer en hacerlo presente el
certamen de belleza más importante del
mundo miss universo en ocho
oportunidades desde tres distintos
continentes fui la presentadora de los
premios más importantes de la música
premios billboard de la música latina en
cuatro oportunidades desde miami en 2007
telemundo me ofrece volver a noticias
así al rojo vivo fin de semana con
candela ferro
el show lleva mi nombre pero no solo en
eeuu en latinoamérica tenía otro show
que llevaba mi nombre mil preguntas una
estrella con candela ferro entrevisté a
las figuras más importantes del planeta
y me llevo a argentina me llegó a ser un
poquito profeta en mi tierra
almorcé con mirtha legrand y me
entrevisto jorgelin sur dos pioneros dos
leyendas con los que yo había crecido en
el living de casa en reconquista
cuando gustavo le volvió a hacer la
pregunta tan temida tú qué quieres hacer
esta vez no me dio miedo
esta vez habrás el caos
esta vez sonreía el miedo
sabía que quería entrevistar
que tengo un don innato para la
conversación que me interesa la vida de
otros aquellas vidas que transforman
gente y que transforman lugares que life
is no fe que en televisión hoy estás y
mañana no sé pero es lo que sea hacer lo
que me apasiona y les confieso aún
quiero morir
hoy me levanté temprano sea mía mi
hermano lucas y le dije lucas te
imaginas si hubiera dicho que se ha
impuesto de azafrán
lucas se rió y me dijo nunca hubieras
dicho que si no era lo que querías hacer
cuando tú estás segura no escuchas a
nadie
lo corregí si me escucho a mí misma
y sabes nivel
solo
[Música]